what's a Nintendo video game console
that had a bunch of weird sports games
we've got another one Myra tennis is
back it is not butterworth hello is it
good not really great that's pretty much
the interactive austintx but i really
want to my review to just be a gif of me
going it's mine yeah like that really
could have been the review is it these
games seem to fall into two camps the oh
it's his mediocre as you might expect to
this is a surprisingly good one like you
re o strikers charged this is a
surprisingly good one yeah like what was
the Mario the tennis game on gamecube
that was one I really was that and then
one in 64 is well if the first mario
tennis on six worthless excellent like I
played a lot of that actually big I
played a lot of goldeneye and they would
alternate over tomorrow tennis when we
needed a palate cleansers there's a lot
of those to both of which are incredibly
frustrating play with your friends were
better than you though so i don't
recommend building friendships on either
of those games so mario tennis ultra
smash through ultra smashed but
assaulters they get was that the
remember they did that whole des thing
were like it was like every game had
like a des subtitle well yeah extra for
the wii u is that what they're doing not
that I'm aware of I mean maybe you've
stumbled onto a really fascinating
naming trends that none of us noticed
reading between the lines but look this
looks rad what's wrong with you Scott
look Mario's huge it actually tells it
what I pretty good I mean it's it's a
very pretty game and it's got those like
you know flashy trails behind the ball
when you hit it a certain way to play
tube this is a two player so i will say
that being able to use the the player
the gamepad is the second screen makes
local multiplayer a lot more fun because
you can I just have yeah yeah and the
camera angle exactly how you want it
it's like you kind of want the camera
behind your avatar we're playing and so
this allows two players to have that so
local multiplayers in a way benefits
from that pretty substantially even
though they don't use the gamepad in any
like more creative ways beyond that I'll
still nice to have a lot of games
haven't been doing that even from
Nintendo the the Wii U gamepad is
basically reverted to being a second
screen and so many games I think have
just shifted over to that instead of
trying to make this do something you new
or unique original here's a way for you
to play this game and let them
we also use the TV because they probably
don't want to watch you play this game
yeah i've been playing mario maker all
weekend and it really enjoying that sort
of whole experience yeah you saved a lot
of nice things about this mario tennis
game why does it only get six out of ten
school so loses a lot of points simply
because it's it's a very empty game it's
just very bare-bones like the least
amount of stuff you could put in a game
like okay we're done here you go it's
like there's no tournament mode there's
no real like campaign or career or
anything Wow yeah there's nothing really
to like work towards there's no
progression of any kind like you can
unlock their a handful of weird like
cartoony courts that you can unlock and
they're like kind of fun but it's like
really not much to work towards so the
biggest issues just the game is really
empty it was like nothing like the older
games like the gamecube game had these
wild minigames that gives the mechanics
and sort of interesting ways and all the
characters had different power shots
that were unique to those characters so
depending on who you were playing would
change the experience in some way but
there's nothing that meaningfully new
meaningfully changes the mechanics that
this game is just like yeah you can hit
a ball back and forth bunch Lantana's
woo and like fun Yoshi's Nucky's paid
pad it's like the biggest thing that
edit this time was mega battle which is
basically a quick play mode in which a
little toad so you can see hanging out
on the side the court there will toss
mega mushrooms at you and your character
will like grow to super size for a brief
period of time but if both characters
are super sized and like it's almost
impossible to miss because you're so big
like incident reach yeah so it just
turns into like a meaningless volley for
a minute as you wait for the other
personal shrink and then if you shrink
at the wrong time you don't have any
control over when you shrink back down
to your regular size and if the ball
happens to be coming towards you when
you shrink you'll probably just miss it
and you'll lose a point simply because
of just poor luck I mean it doesn't
indicate that it's about to happen even
if you knew sometimes the timing works
out that you couldn't do anything about
it anyway and you're just oh you shrank
and the ball went past you because
you're suddenly like a way less real and
you just get screwed by the game it's
like how did no one think of this
Academy bow look at all the Evo's yeah
even the amoeba functionality is like
hina bare bones like you can bring them
along with you in like the closest thing
to a campaign that this game has which
is like a ladder style playing every
character in a row increasingly
difficult and you can drag an amiibo
character along with you for that you
can actually say online they just sit on
the baseline
yeah they can hand on the baseline like
anything you miss them i pick up
although i experimented with it to see
exactly how much help they would give
you and basically if you return the
serve and then just run away they will
pretty much take care of things for you
again kind of hilarity level up faster
if you make them do that I don't know
but you can level them which is
important like if you really knew
amiibos you can actually level them up
by playing the the latter mode and you
can bring them online as well so you
have a little like extra help that your
amiibo buddy online is better as a
result of that training although
anything that you do with a me Bo can
only be saved to that's one game like if
you want to use that amigo then and
super smash brothers you have to delete
all of that data you can't carry the
walking games that's the way the way a
meebo work so like to leave the data yes
it won't even just like leave it there
no it'll just know you lose that data
net well that's deleted from your
character you have to move it over he is
your Daisy no good at tennis in smash
bros but she's also no good at tennis
and tennis game anymore yeah meebo still
hasn't found that hook that makes it a
really good game and it has cuz it's
sold millions yeah who's buying all
these e me bows all right i do question
Justin who is who was buying as we
demand answers I only have like 40 haha
I was really just what I tried other
Nintendo characters hoping that there
would be like secret character unlocks
no like it's only the characters that
are in the game so it's like warriors in
the game if you have Wario me about
that'll work that's like link link me
but didn't work oh really nope don't you
unlock like slightly more sparkly gold
versions of all the characters yeah like
you eventually like when you beat the
ladder mode you unlock like the star
version of that character and like
you've little star icon on the menu but
I couldn't actually figure out how that
impacted like what it did they glow like
I would assume that it makes the
character like better but I don't know
what that means and like it didn't have
a tangible impact on the gameplay they
didn't really look different than really
play different so it's like why did I
bother grinding all the way through this
like ladder match mode to Bible you now
you're going to tennis you're a tennis
player you're a tennis pro yeah so I
think what I didn't feel worth it I
think it's a problem for Nintendo's work
for what people think of the wii u that
these kind of games are coming out late
in the year because they've had a really
good year yeah sure and now we're having
these kind of lackluster final titles of
Animal Crossing amiibo festival this in
just from Nintendo in general tri Force
heroes
games the kind of fuel have to bake like
they're good they're mechanically solid
they look good they sound good but
there's a lot missing and it feels like
you maybe they're rushed out and I think
part of that might be because we're
going to see the NX next year because I
for the long time I've been thinking
like they're gonna announce the next
year it'll come out even later this
feels like they're gearing up to
announce and ship the NX next year
because these games they're just pushing
these out it's going all wacky sports
tiles SAT there especially when you look
at like how much they put into a meebo
and then you have such limited
functionality for all times like it
feels like if they were really trying to
push something with this and games that
are just missing it entirely like tri
Force heroes if they were really
something behind these if they needed
them to incubate longer they would have
put all that functionality into it and I
think they're just getting rid of these
titles now to shift over last question
for you Scott the game seems shallow it
seems enjoyable in some respect those
still got a six out of town gamespot
yeah is this something you might
consider you know recommending people
pick up if it hits like thirty dollars
something like that I mean it's up to
you how much you want to spend on games
right i mean for certain people thirty
dollars is still a lot of money for some
shell sixty dollars isn't a lot of money
or fifty dollars i mean it just depends
yeah i mean it did get a six of six is a
fair score you know doesn't mean the
game is bad just means that it could
have been quite a bit better yeah and
the thing that really saved for me is
that the local multiplayer is pretty fun
i mean it is a competently executed
tennis game with like the fun colors of
a Mario sports game you know so if you
have people that you like to have over
to your house to sit down and play games
especially like kind of light fun party
games they're easy to pick up and kind
of competitive but not to you know crazy
or in depth this is a fun one to pick up
for for that kind of circumstance
anything else probably not so much but
if you're that kind of person in that
kind of gamer this could totally be
something that you'll have some fun with
what if you're like me and you let alone
and live sadly and just sit around and
play games when your underwear while
eating cookie dough that's what like
League of Legends is for me haha alright
Scott ball just kidding just kidding
guys your skin it is a yeah all the law
fountains just go out of your lucky
travis gafford was here yesterday would
have taken oh yeah there are several
people who would punch me in the face
for saying i'm glad none of them are on
this couch I just in thanks coming on
thank you as ever
I was ever thank you for your review as
you want to read the full review sup on
gamespot com 6 out of 10 is a score but
make sure you go over there check the
written review or it was our video
review your woman there was not as one
minute review on facebook okay so there
is you have to read actual words to get
the read actual words you got to work
for it yep let us know what you think of
the latest mario tennis game if you play
to yourself ultra smash ultra smashes
and the comment box below